oh you think it's fall pumpkin it's all
about what about domination did your
relationship with Maleficent really stop
you from reconnecting with your daughter
mal or did you find it too hard to own
up to your mistakes oh Hades we know
you're a villain but you've obviously
seen the error of your ways otherwise
you never would have given Mau the ember
and saved Audrey you're a good guy Hades
you can't hide that from us
why was he he's missing from the first
two movies and why did he come back in
descendant three here's what he was
doing and why the descendants three we
know and love wouldn't have been
possible without him hi dad
first things first what was Hades doing
during the first and second descendants
movies he didn't make his big entrance
until descendants three but we know his
home was on the Isle of the Lost
how was he fulfilling his time
eagle-eyed fans have a pretty good idea
there's a big clue in descendants two
near the curl up and die salon where
dizzy works there's a poster on the wall
it says Katie's souvlaki it's under this
world it would be totally appropriate if
Hades was making and selling Greek food
after all he's the god of the underworld
in ancient Greek mythology and souvlaki
is a popular fast food in Greece made up
of small pieces of meat grilled on a
skewer given that he's associated with
flames and fire selling Tsubaki makes
perfect sense but can you really see
Hades being satisfied selling snacks to
villains nope
nor can we so perhaps he actually
focused his times on rocking out when
mal meets up with him in his lair on the
Isle he's clearly a frustrated rock star
maybe he's been practicing his riffs and
dreaming of going on tour when he
finally finds a way off the Isle of
course Hades does eventually get
released from the Isle of the Lost and
it's all thanks to mal and that's the
key reason why he came back in d3 it's
all about mal we learned a lot about
mouths difficult relationship with her
mom Maleficent in the first movie but
then the second movie hardly touched on
Mouse family at all so to bring in her
dad in the
installment helped fans understand
exactly where Mao comes from the fact
that all the villains on the aisle are a
single parents isn't explicitly dealt
with in the films but fans have picked
up on the detail and it's raised lots of
questions about the V case missing
parents he's not going anywhere till we
get rid of this unibrow by bringing
Hades into d3s a movie makers gave fans
a much greater insight into mal she's
the main character so it makes sense
that her family members are important
mouths blood linked to Haiti shows up
straight away when she passes through
the barrier to the Isle after all her
hair turns blue once she gets her hands
on the ember' let's not forget that hey
December was really the key to the plot
in d3 - it was the major player in
defeating Audrey and in bringing mala
Numa back together with a renewed
friendship sure the filmmakers could
have chosen any magical object but it
needed to come from mouths dad to work
with the plot lines about mouths powers
it was also a clever twist to make
mouths dad's magical objects the only
thing more powerful than mouths mom's
magical objects
[Music]
aka Maleficent scepter Hades ember also
shows us that despite his heinous crimes
in the past he's a reformed character if
he were still evil he wouldn't have let
mal have the Ember when she visited him
on the Isle and also he wouldn't have
secretly passed mal the Ember for her to
keep after he woke up Audrey a truly
evil villain wouldn't have helped to
revive an a Kay like Audrey either so
with Hades positive character traits the
audience gets another example of how the
good evil divide is not so
straightforward that's a key message in
d3 is so much so that mal makes a speech
about it she says we're all capable of
good and bad no matter which side of the
barrier we come from and her dad is
proof that even the most rotten to the
core villains can change their ways you
never know where the bad is gonna come
from and you never know where the heroes
are gonna come from either as for Hades
in mouths future we'd love to see more
members of their family on screen after
all Hades has a son called Haiti in the
novels by Melissa de la Cruz these
mouths brother wouldn't it be awesome to
see how their family would reconnect
now that the barrier to the Isle is down
we're not sure we can see Maleficent in
Hades rekindling their romance though no
I left your mother post exciting new
descendants theories every week so if
you haven't already make sure to
subscribe to the things remember to turn
on those post notifications too so you
can be the first to watch our newest
videos if you're watching the things on
your mobile you can turn on
notifications in the YouTube settings so
that's a wrap on the real reason Hades
came back in d3 which descendants
villain is your favorite let us know in
the comments give this video a big
if you love descendants thanks for
watching we'll see you next time on the
themes
[Music]